CBS News has learned that the number of
people caught illegally crossing in the
United States northern border is up 142
% Border Patrol agents apprehended 445
people entering the u.s. from Canada
during the first six months of 2018 now
that compares with 184 during the same
period last year Don Dahler traveled to
Derby Line Vermont for an up-close look
at security along the u.s. Canadian
border good morning these flower pots
mark the northern border which actually
goes right through the Haskell Free
Library and opera house I'm standing in
Vermont if I take a step that way I'm in
Quebec as you can see the board is very
easy to cross here which was actually
the original intention but it also makes
it very difficult to secure this
unguarded metal fence is the only thing
preventing criminal gangs drug smugglers
and human traffickers from entering this
remote corner of New York does this
represent the physical security
infrastructure along the northern border
this is a part of that yes a gate with a
lock yes yes normal egg is the Border
Patrol agent in charge here
he says it's impossible to cover the
entire five thousand five hundred and
twenty-five mile long u.s. Canadian
border the longest and busiest land
boundary in the world it's basically a
big game of whack-a-mole it's a tough
challenge we have work in such a vast
area last year Border Patrol agents
along the northern border caught 3,000
27 people who were in the country
illegally
nearly half 1400 and 89 were from Mexico
which is on the southern border Mexican
citizens don't need a visa to enter
Canada and one-way flights to Toronto
and Montreal only cost about $300 once
their Border Patrol agents say they can
slip into the u.s. a major city like New
York is only six hours away the Train is
very difficult to work in and do not
have the resources at our disposal that
seven many official ports of entry like
this floating dock near Lake Champlain
are unmanned at night
champagne sensors and patrols help fill
in the security gaps there are thousands
of sensors like this one deployed along
the northern border that incorporate
motion detection and cameras when they
sense someone coming across the tricky
part is getting a Border Patrol agent
there and time enough to catch them
sometimes entering the u.s. is as simple
as crossing a 20 foot wide clearing in
the woods or paddling across a lake and
you don't have to check in with anyone
I'm not seeing any markers on this Lake
it's pretty unmarked and Porter Fox is
author of Northland a book about what he
calls America's forgotten border it's
generally agreed that the northern
border is more vulnerable to a terrorist
sneaking into this country the only
known terrorists to be apprehended
coming overland into America came from
the north it was created as the world's
friendliest border between two countries
there's a lot at stake up here in the
north many buildings and businesses
literally straddled the northern border
and the illegal traffic goes both ways
just last January a Canadian man pled
guilty to smuggling handguns through
this library into Canada Heller
reporting there with a really
fascinating story
I think so too the border doesn't get
friendlier if it's lined with flowerpots
know exactly